y no se resuelve la crisis económica
poniendo o generando más que el
incremento del precio de los
combustibles ha encarecido la vida más
de 67 por ciento de la población
económicamente activa no tiene empleo
compañeras y compañeros
[Música]
a merchán
si es que el día de hoy el presidente de
la república da respuestas entonces el
día de hoy levantaremos si el presidente
de la república no da respuestas a
ninguno de los puntos entonces nos
mantenemos de manera indefinida
[Música]
los hermanos en vigo
mujercitas para las guardias
[Música]
para aprender
esta chispa
compañeros presidentes
[Música]
y
y en este tiempo
hay muchos avances pero no hay un
acuerdo en ese sentido esperamos sobre
la voluntad que ha sido expresada en la
mesa de diálogo se pueda concluir pero
los temas que tan así
[Música]
[Aplausos]